pas de thème chaque artiste est libre
dans sa créativité l'exposition art
talent débuté il ya un mois a pris fin
le 19 mai avec sa traditionnelle remise
des prix c'est la quatrième édition à
chaque fois un invité d'honneur
un jury différent ce qui laisse une
diversité de prix puisque nous avons
trois prix plus le prix public et ça
permet à ce moment là d'avoir une
diversité de talents exposés chaque
année des merveilles différents suivant
les esthétiques du jury à travers ses
peintures cil que questionner dévoile
l'animalité qui sommeille en l'homme
elle est l'invitée d'honneur de
l'édition 2019
il expose sa série human birds j'étais
très honoré c'est une nouvelle
expérience aussi d'être dans un jury de
pouvoir
défendre des artistes l'heure des
récompenses est arrivé le versaillais
daniel convenant remporte le prix du
jury avec sa technique originale des
peintures ou bitume présentement on m'a
même déjà parce qu'un parent et original
parler de lui-même et son vécu à et donc
ça ça fait partie 1 représente un
paysage sir alice parce qu'avant je
faisais des les peintures curieux prix
de la ville une peintre évinoise
origines italiennes ces paysages
réalisés en collant des papiers de soie
parents lui ont été inspirées au retour
d'un voyage en résidence d'artiste
encore et ça me fait plaisir mais je ne
m'attendais absolument pas donc je
tremble encore ça me fait plaisir que
mon travail soit reconnu et que ça
plaise à des gens qui par exemple que je
connais pas la ville entend bien
réaliser une cinquième édition toujours
dans cet objectif de découverte de
nouveaux talents pour deux nouvelles
expositions